what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today so i am
going to be doing a movie reaction today
for the green mile because i put out
three movies on the community post and
you guys voted and this was easily the
top vote which i feel is that because
you know like i've been catching up on
some classic films so i watched you know
forrest gump here on the channel
starring tom hanks and then i watched
shawshank redemption eventually which is
directed by frank darabon taking place
in a prison and now i learned this today
like frank darabont he directed this
movie and it stars tom hanks so it feels
like it's it's completing some weird
trilogy of sorts
i'm excited to check it out if you can i
know you can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe and
click the notification bell we are
planning on covering more movies on this
channel even the ones that uh did not
get the number one vote i do want to
actually get around to watching those as
well and also full-length reaction watch
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy for the green mile and along with a
bunch of other movies and shows that we
covered here on the channel or over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects
and there's also shows over there where
they are exclusively covered at our
patreon with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included lastly thank you
to the team at prepper for helping us
edit this down it's a long movie so i
just gotta settle in relax and then see
what evokes a reaction let's get to it
[Music]
oh [ __ ] is this sadler again
[Music]
uh what
you look tired you're not yourself i
just didn't sleep well zone i had a few
bad dreams it happens
i'll be fine
what what did you dream about
[Music]
is he supposed to be like tom hanks
they're doing one of those saving
private ryan thingies i know that wasn't
tom hanks the beginning of seven prayer
run i ever tell you that i was a prison
guard during the depression
the dimension that i was
in charge of death row that i supervised
all the executions
yikes
death row is called the last mile
we called ours the green mile all right
you're right in there
pissing razor blaze yeah
god i've never had a uti they've never
sounded pleasant
dead man walking here
dead man
we got a dead man walking here my god
dude
i'm not gonna have any trouble with you
big boy
can you tell
yes suppose
i can talk
man rest in peace michael clark duncan
you're moving house down the infirmary
why don't you go see if they can use
some help
uh-uh i don't care where you go for us
he's just a moment's not here this very
moment
get the [ __ ] out percy do you leave the
light on after bedtime cause i get a
little scared in the dark sometime
if it's a strange plate
[Laughter]
[Music]
stays
pretty bright around here all night long
we always keep a few lights burning on
the cardo
shake his hair come on
you can see it
well i'm so used to michael clark duncan
playing
like really tough guys
is he [ __ ] you figure
looks like they sent us a hand until
they execute ambassador he deserves to
fry for what he done
make your blood cuddle
so i'm already under the impression he
did not do whatever he is being in
prison for
[Music]
jesus
what does that mean
linda's not so well paul
i'm all headaches
got laid up with another one yesterday
there's a lot of sick people in this
movie
like it or not the wife of the governor
of this state has only one nephew and
his name happens to be percy whitman oh
god
look again
is it right
there
oh i wanted why what what
so adorable my cats would destroy that
mess
oh my god they've had to remove
everything to get this one mouse
three grown men
outsmarted my mouse
they're hard to find
what the [ __ ]
dude they're all playing with the mouse
don't don't attack it
are you
i see i'm gonna rip your diseased head
off
through this piece of [ __ ]
this guy is a nut bag
man under strain can snap
that's why our job is
talking not yelling
i think of it as a bucket of piss to
drown rats in are such an [ __ ] we all
know who your connections are percy
you ever threaten a man on this block
again we all gonna have a go
y'all be damned
get all this [ __ ] back in the
restraining room you are cluttering up
my mind
that guy
is so unlikable but that whoever that
actor is he's
really really good at playing that
repulsive [ __ ]
you have anything to say before your
sentence is carried out i'm gonna fried
chicken dinner with gravy on the taters
and i want to [ __ ] in your hat
when we'll remark like that i'll have
van hay roll on too for real okay we'll
be doing this for real tomorrow night
you ever try not to laugh in church when
something funny gets stuck in your head
is the same goddamn thing
yeah this is a little a little worse
one of the witnesses showed up a day
early
[Music]
is this movie really about the mouse
you think if a man sincerely repents on
what he'd done wrong that he might get
to go back to the time that was happiest
for him and
live there forever
uh fascinating question
[Applause]
soak the sponge
conduct electricity right to the brain
got it taking notes for john in the
future
roll on two
god the sound design on this
oh my god
oh
that is brutal
adios chief
drive us a card from hell
let's know if it's hot enough
what the [ __ ] you disrespectful [ __ ]
you square with a house again
so keep a goddamn hands off him
what's up his ass
you
yeah i want brutal spot for the next
execution
you said distinct [ __ ] and if i say
no
i might just stick around for good
make me a career of this
are you
sleazy slimy scum i hate this guy so
much
[Laughter]
i don't think that mouse
mr jingles
[Music]
oh what a cute little guy i love him so
much
they're some smart mouse still
like your circus mouth something when i
get out of here it's going to make me
rich you just watch it see if you don't
do that this [ __ ] better not do
anything to that goddamn mouse i swear
to god it's a two
mobo a brain tumor
oh no
it's the size of the lemon they said
that's not good at all
i can't think how to tell my wife
she's going to die
[Music]
it's kind of this uh
interesting theme of like death being
the ultimate punishment
[Music]
god i can feel it
i've never had it
there's been some painful stuff before
you know
what's that was a kid tattoo
holy [ __ ] is that sam rockwell
you've been declared competent son
man you gonna ride the light
damn
question
shut up give us a hand here
is this
an act or something no
yep it's an act
[Applause]
ouch
oh no
[Music]
percy get your hillbilly ass in there
[Music]
you warning me
what the hell percy
go get dean harry looked at make sure
they're all right
first thing you make the report
warden for me
start out by saying the situation's up
god damn
balls
what about you you're already collapse
ah i got the mile
until you all come back
god damn tom hanks really is a great
actor huh
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you want john coffee just to
help
oh my god
what is going on right now
oh my god he's got some type of
superpower oh what oh [ __ ]
[Music]
shut up
what is going on like an hour into this
movie what is happening here
[Applause]
oh does he like absorb the
illness and disperse it afterwards
didn't i help it
i just took it back
oh my god he was trying to save those
two girls
go take a piss paul go take a beautiful
piss paul
oh [ __ ] he was trying to save those two
[Music]
honey we're making love
i feel like that should feel left field
which is happening such a surprise but
it's like weirdly blended in with
the actual tone of the movie impressive
direction
[Music]
what are you doing
what does it feel like
[Music]
nice work there paul
[Laughter]
my man
that's a weird
two seconds to throw in
go to the morning it's funny i'm not
sure what i'm sure of
[Applause]
what are
you investigating
garrison oh my god it's a forest gump
reunion
coffee
you came up here to see if i think he
did it at all
once seldom sees a less ambiguous case
he was found with the victims in his
arms and yet you defended him
everyone is entitled to defense
but he didn't believe
are there any sick people in this home
he can heal we had us a dog
please sir
yikes
i suppose he's
lucky not to be completely blind
we get down on our knees and thank god
for that much at least
can john coffey heal that eye is coffee
guilty
yes he is nah man cough is totally
innocent you didn't tell him the ball
story
she wanna
thank you
for helping me helping you with
oh your misses please
several times
[Laughter]
it's yours joe
you can do it as he please oh he's so
nice
what about me don't you hold down on me
you big dummy
you'll keep a civil town on my block
oh you prick
yeah
piss on me
[Applause]
say with i'm
back to the door killed by a drunk oh my
son's embody a history lesson
thank you
[Applause]
terry is very believable
all i wanted me was a little cornbread
you [ __ ]
all i wanted was a little cornbread
there are some disgusting ass people in
this movie
oh no
oh god oh no
oh man you gone done it yeah i'll grab a
few things it's a big day for you and mr
jingles important folks heard about your
mouse
we'll see him perform not just prison
cards either one's a politician all the
way from the state capitol i believe
what is really happening
this is great
mr jingles oh i love mr james they laugh
over there
well that's just aces
taste of your own medicine
i'm just playing
but smell you
oh god
you know prison bands
[Laughter]
this is not going to amount to something
good
you talk about this to anyone
i get you all fired what happens on a
mile
stays on the mile always has
but there's been a bunch of embarrassing
[ __ ] that's happened you live out in the
woods
mr jingle he be
he'd be scared to live out in the big
woods no
how about a mouse bill
toys retracting down florida
tallahassee i think
is that right paul tallahassee yeah yeah
tallahassee
i think they're making [ __ ] up that's
the place for mr james
you're gonna be as sick as miles a doll
[Music]
mr jingles
[Applause]
what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no
you killed my mom well i knew i'd get
them sooner or later
it's just a matter of time really
you [ __ ]
i cruel can't believe it
give them to me oh yes
[Music]
i completely forgot
mr jingles lips
he did that to my balls
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that means it works right
[Music]
mr jingles
is alive
john covey
what did you
do i have dale's mouse
your circus mouse
gonna live in a mouse city
down in
this movie is going to be so [ __ ]
depressing
you come along with me
you fellas going back to your village
game
you guys those are black jesus in prison
oh there's still like nine or four
minutes ago
don't forget about mouthfeel
there's no such place
just all you should know what a prick
oh he's not gonna wet it is he
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh this is so infuriating
you like feel or see that it's not wet
there's no no water trail
roll on two
[Applause]
ah that's horrifying
like he's connected to it in some way
[Music]
oh
man he did it
oh poor dale
you are one of the worst characters in
history man i can feel it from here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i would just commit my life to
understanding what the hell this john
coffey guy is capable of doing you could
take him to heal james cromwell's wife
she's not herself anymore
she swears
she swears just pops out most awful
language you can imagine
she doesn't even know she's doing it
words like damn hell [ __ ]
i'm thinking i don't know what i would
do if you were gone
i'm also thinking i want to have the
boys over tomorrow
well you sure do know how to cook
chicken he's gonna he's gonna
pitch the idea huh
sneak a sick woman into a sale blog oh
no no no no hal would never stand for
that
you know him he wouldn't believe
anything if it fell on him so you're
talking about
taking john coffee to hurt
how would you guys not be obsessed with
understanding what's going on come on
boss
i mean i've been doing all day
it's hot in here
y'all get to drink i'm thirsty
man no one else could have played
michael clark duncan's role no one else
could have played it
maybe al pacino i'll be good
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
give you a few hours of quiet time percy
so you can reflect
on what you did to dale and if you're
lonely just think about this led by
[Laughter]
i'll take y'all a few hours for you back
whoa
[Music]
you're bad
man
oh no no no
why are you still tying back
[Music]
false love
they did not run this by him now we are
here to help what
i don't understand
you're just gonna you're gonna have to
trust me
give some context man i don't want to
get shot
[Music]
this guy's so nice
breaks my heart
what's your name
giant coffee ma'am
like to
drink it's a hell of a tumor
[Applause]
[Music]
much better
did i have the x-ray
yes
yes
it was clear
there was no tumor
poor poor guy's crying about his life
soul movement
jesus
no you can't
what a weird spiritual experience this
story is here
[Music]
let me out of this nut coat in a minute
now right now i want out now
[ __ ] slap will smith's lap
let bygones be bygones
no one ever need know about that except
the
people in this little realm
what happens in a mile stays on the mile
and you're technically still in the mile
[Music]
oh he's gonna transfer it
what's gonna happen
what's about to i have no idea what's
going on right now
what you looking at
you lamp noodle
you won't kiss my ass
it won't suck my dick
oh he's gonna kill him isn't he
what the hell is going on
i saw in his heart
when he grabbed my arm you see for
yourself
[Music]
those biscuits looking really good
[Music]
damn it's creepy son of a [ __ ] that did
it you love your sister
[Music]
oh man he doesn't want to live does he
does this have anything to do with what
happened in my house
no
interesting time for some quirky no
music
oh my god has he been condemned to the
mental hospital does hell know
that coffee's innocent i mean
does he have the influence to do
something about this no
if it can't help don't tell him and my
killing
sam rockwell
never got a test
testimony
meatloaf be nice
mashed taters gravy
okra maybe some of that fine cornbridge
mrs make
if she don't mind
i have to ask you something very
important now
i know what you're gonna say
you don't have to say it
when i stand before god
and he asks me why
did i kill one of his true
miracles
what am i going to say you tell god the
father
it was the kindness you've done
show
[Music]
[Music]
i'll be all right fellas
this here's the hard part
i'll be all right in the water he's
comforting them
my dream mr jingles got down to that
place boss howard talked about
that mouseville place
i dreamed as kids
and how they laughed at his tricks my
oh boy
these laughing too
i put my arms around them and set them
on my knees
and there's no blood coming out of their
head and he's just fine
mr jacobs rolling that spoon
how we did laugh at the bus we were
[ __ ] this is like rather because it was
like
you was gonna die
these lots of folks here hate me it's
like be stinging me
i feel how we feel then we don't hate
you
can you feel that
kill him twice you boys oh [ __ ] you
deserve
wipe your face before you stand up dean
yes
christ does it hurt yet
i hope it does
i hope it hurts like hell
oh my gosh
i'm sorry for what i am
please both
don't put that thing for my face
don't put me in the dark
[Music]
this doesn't feel real
all right
thinking like something's gonna get him
out of it
my heart's just all numb right
now i'm like mad right now
may god
have mercy on your soul
yeah you have to give the order
no
on two
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good
[Music]
oh it doesn't
doesn't feel right
you know
says feel fair
does it feel fair
[Music]
i just couldn't do it anymore after that
you said you and jan
had a grown son in 1935
do you feel up to taking a walk
listen to a story for three hours
talk about that one detail huh
there
hey
wake up oh fella
wake up
no [ __ ]
oh it isn't it can't be
come over here boy
that can't be mr jingles
how is he still kicking
go on
you can do it
this isn't exactly the mouseville we had
in mind is it
what we may do
don't we fella
he doesn't care he's content i think
when we electrocuted dale whatever magic
was inside of him
just slipped into my tiny friend here
john had to give me a part of himself so
that i could see for myself what wild
bill had done
a part of the power
spilled into me
he infected you with life
it's a good word as any
i'm 108 years old elaine
[Music]
i've had to see my friends and loved
ones die off through the years
you'll die too
[Music]
it's my punishment
for letting john coffee ride the
lightning
for killing the miracle of god oh that
is
tragic that's so tragic
mr jingles
where you been
hey
if he could make a mouse
lifts alone
how much longer do i have
we each owe a death
sometimes
the green mile
seems so long
very poetic
wow
that was a hell of a movie
holy balls
i love that
i
i love that movie that's a stephen king
movie again i didn't know that
all right let's uh
let's chat about it she's just
got to take that in a little bit already
okay
well ladies and gentlemen
it's pretty late at night
the movie's over three hours it's like a
tad bit over three hours but it went by
pretty fast for me
the only time i became more of the run
time when i was like i am starting to be
a little bit tired
and i am hungry
so when that surf kick and i'm like
okay yeah so forgive me for the people
who stick around for the actual review
portion
yeah well i am i i might not speak for
as extensively as i normally prefer to
given the nature of a
film like this which had so much going
for it and uh one that i loved then
honestly
you know like i was kind of joking
talking about it at the beginning and
you know and seeing people like gary
sinise pop up in here knowing frank
derek directed it
uh tom hanks and starring in this yeah
this did feel like the perfect third
film so i'm glad this was the one that
was voted for after watching because i
watched some other films in between that
we put up on this channel but you know
like forrest gump shawshank and then
this
and
honestly you know like i i feel like
most people will probably go
with one of those as their favor between
the three
i feel like
like my my hunch is telling me i'm going
to be in in the unpopular opinion here
but i i
feel like this is my favorite of the
three uh i i personally prefer this one
out of the three
and
i don't really want to spend my time
comparing as to why
just this one really clicked for me i i
like the darkness
of it yet it still had those qualities
of
leaning into love and light things that
really
play
on my tender my tender heart at times
and so
yeah and i really thought this was a a
beautiful ex it was an experience you
know and i loved
story structure wise of you're you're
setting up all these things in place
and i think i said it out loud like
where is this movie going exactly like i
i don't really know what's what's
becoming
of any of this or what it's all going to
ultimately unify into even though i was
enjoying it right from the beginning and
i was like kind of falling in love with
the
with the with the whole mood and and
tone of it all
throughout
i went by time it came together and you
know halfway through once the
supernatural element of it
you know like you start seeing the
religious symbolisms and and what
they're playing on but even if you which
i'll i'll dive into a little bit of that
but even if you remove
a lot of those qualities i still feel
like
that even if you're not picking up
on what are some very
obvious you know religious connections
and symbolisms
for crying out loud the guy is called
john coffey jc jesus christ healer
you know
condemned when he shouldn't be like this
there's there's a lot of you know
christian allegories and they talk
you know bluntly about
god and will my soul be saved and
there's like things about here that feel
like pontius pilate
related you know i i don't identify
anymore as a catholic but i did grow up
in the catholic church
for for a large portion of my life and
you know
and so and i feel like a lot of people
are familiar with the story of jesus
christ anyway even if you're not
christian catholic or whatever
denomination you belong to or don't i'm
sure you've heard the story before right
so yeah there's some obvious very
very obvious religious allegories i
thought very well told and even if you
removed that like just from a filmmaking
level i think the pacing is strong
obviously when a movie's this long
you're gonna have people who will at
times be like yeah this is this is long
this is this is going on a while but to
me i enjoyed every moment of it like
there isn't a story
point or a scene
that bored me whatsoever or i never felt
you know even though i questioned you
know i wonder where where this is all
gonna ultimately land i never questioned
where it was
you know like when when's this movie
gonna get going when's the train gonna
start moving along here you know because
sometimes you can feel that with films
like
come on come on don't don't be
self-indulgent here and i didn't find it
self-indulgent you know the knowing
especially that's a stephen king book i
imagine there's probably even way more
in that book
than what's in this film itself and i
think that the everything they included
i thought was very much necessary
uh i loved
absolutely loved the performances of
both tom hanks and michael clark duncan
like there's so much
going on for both of those characters
without it even having to fully be said
well more stuff gets
said in a more overt way later on in
this film but you're like it's a
three-hour movie you've earned some
expositional dialogue to just state
everything by that point
i i i think that
um you know like with what starting with
tom hanks
his character right from the beginning
you just instantly get like this is an
amazing tom hanks performance to me
i saw the movie elvis
i really liked the movie elvis i know i
haven't talked about it at all on this
channel
and it is just kind of fun to see
like well i thought tom hanks was good i
never just saw tom i never just saw the
character he was playing in that film
i think maybe the style and some of the
choices in the makeup i i just couldn't
get swept up in specifically his
performance even it was one of those
weird things where i had a dichotomy of
he's doing a great job
yet
i don't ever just see the character i'm
fully aware this is tom hanks the whole
time so to to go back like a couple
decades earlier and see this performance
which is not too long after forrest gump
i i thought he was very believable and i
and and i was really quick into it that
i just got swept up in the character
itself like
his character you could feel the there's
this connection of empathy between
you know john coffey and paul edgecombe
is his last name or paul uh yeah you
have this connection between paul the
apostle you have this connection of
john coffey and paul and
there's they both have this empathetic
quality about them and and i loved just
just how worn out how weary
tom hanks character was in this film
right from the get-go beyond struggling
with some physical ailment with the with
the with the uti problem
he was
someone who could tell
like because of the kind of character he
was with the job that he held there was
an empathetic approach to the characters
in in the prison you know and there's a
there's a lot of commentary to be made
about
the prison system you know i feel like
that talk comes up way more now than
ever i mean especially like for probably
back then people fighting give a [ __ ]
you know uh but you know there's a plus
the the death penalty is something that
i've heard debated about many times
and then here you know when you're
like do you even get a chance for reform
you get a chance for penance like do you
you get a proper chance and
that empathetic quality i thought held
so strong with with tom hanks's
performance and how much the toll on
this was
taking on him and you watch that toll
it so
like subtly and internally take over him
as this movie progresses and
you know that his like
even if i'm not a religious man
that
debate
that he has with himself at the end of
i've clearly met a miracle man
what what the [ __ ] am i gonna tell god
as to like how i did not even fight
to save this man's life
that's just uh it was heartbreaking it
and then with
john coffey as this
you know beyond the religious points you
could see
you know
it wasn't something that
because you know the
misplacement of crime criminal
activities and there are stories that
you know other movies have told them uh
of different versions of swords of this
but yes we all know
it's not something that just because we
all know should just be brushed yeah we
know it doesn't matter just to be
rushing on the rug
but there have been a lot of
terrible injustices done to black men in
like throughout history and then
to this day even
where
you're
guilty
we're just presumed guilty right away
you know and then also for this
situation of
what happened to these children
of it being blamed on this black man
and just
you know instantly
yep
he did it
granted you know because i had to kind
of fight with myself there
in the end when you know the will i
think that's william sadler and how he
was protesting and saying kill him twice
at the end you know like the truth never
came out and
based off of the optics around the
situation because i immediately didn't
believe
john coffey killed those girls but then
the way the movie handled the flashback
on the perspective of how the bodies
were discovered i was like oh
did he kill them because it certainly
looks that way it would it would appear
that way without knowing all the the
additional context on top of that so i i
thought this movie was going to go down
more that path of of commentating on
that but i think because you do have
john coffey
just as a black man
falsely convicted condemned to death of
this like a lot of that commentary is
being taken care of just with the
picture it has painted around that
already and i was more surprised by all
the
religious
connections that the film was drawing
throughout the the the christian
parallels i know i'm hopping all over
the place i tend to do this with a movie
that's this effective it's not going to
be smooth stream here of me talking
about it i'm going to i'm going to go
around
uh
because yeah his michael clark duncan's
performance was so powerful like
instantly you get the character you know
and michael clark duncan yeah i
i haven't seen
like so much of the the work the man has
done you know like to give you an idea
the last time i saw performance evidence
when i did my first re-watch of the
movie daredevil i watched the director's
cut and like that's more of the michael
clark duncan i kind of know the
the tough guy michael clark duncan
and so to see this performance here
where instantly there is this
this character with so much soul in him
and so much
again the word empathy comes to mind and
like this this giant lovable teddy bear
who
has so much
pain and and
while is so
walking finds so much love and kindness
in this world
he's so isolated you know like to be in
this position just this
it was almost akin to
kind of akin to
i'm using it lightly
to
to what like martin score says you
wanted to explore but last temptation of
jesus christ like what if you really
were this guy how [ __ ] horrible must
it actually be to to be this person you
know to really have to have that weight
of the abilities you have this ability
to connect
yet how much pain and suffering does
that come with and
michael clark duncan embodies that
because
as much hurt as he had it there was
never this
i guess the word i'm looking for is
there's never this rage that he
projected onto people like he never
wanted to as much as punishment was a
vote
justice i could say that's justice you
know like that that ironic karma that
fate because there are similarities in
the sam rockwell character and the percy
character it's like one is it seems like
way worse than like one gets to get away
and do criminal things but in the guise
of you know of the law and and then you
have sam rockwell who is just the scum
of the earth
and i i thought that justice was well
deserved at that moment with the way
that their fates ultimately turned out
uh but
you know it's i it that when you're when
i try to put myself in the position of
like what michael clark duncan's going
through i was just feeling like mad you
know before before the handshake came up
because there's been there was so much
about the connection and the importance
of the handshake
at the electric chair that
uh i was just like mad when he was about
to be
anything about be
i'm either gonna like be moved to tears
or be really angry when it comes to
watching someone be treated unfairly you
know and then him
sort of
being so accepting of death and then
as he's being walked down the green pile
he's looking out
for them and their emotions and the the
the four people who does feel akin to
you know the the the roman soldiers um
who
didn't want to but had to
crucify christ
and he's looking out for them you know
and and he's not wishing ill will when
he is in the electric chair he's not
wishing ill will on any of the people
who are
you know condemning him in the crowd
what is that thing that jesus said
forgive them father for they not know
what they do or some thing like i don't
know the quote all right so yeah they
having
having those characters there i thought
was really strong and and i i really
liked i think the actor's name is david
morse the uh
brutal brute was saying brutal brute
the you know the you guys know what i'm
talking about he was great
like
i liked that there was this
soft lonely quality to the man as well
uh
where
there was like this sort of apathetic
nature to him
and he was excellent i really enjoyed
his performance a lot i've seen him in
like other films but this is the first
time i think i've ever seen him in a
movie where i really am gravitated to
the work that he's doing and also has a
strong support system to tom hanks's
character barry pepper another actor who
i've usually seen play like tougher
people
i thought
maybe not the most richly written
character because
i
it's like it seemed like a lot of the
writing was going like david morris tom
hanks a few of the prisoners the actor
who played dell
fantastic because
there's a way to do that performance
that could feel very off-putting and
you're like you're kind of like an icky
guy but i was very much endeared to him
throughout
and it was heartbreaking to see what
happened to him uh and the way how he
died as well
so all the characters i just thought
were really great everyone was fleshed
out so well and there were so many
moving
there's so many parts that were so
moving to me
in a way just by
like a tone poem of a sequence of how
how they would strike it you know like
when it came to james cromwell's wife
and and the scene where and she is is
being saved
by
john coffey that scene in particular i
remember
having a a thought
of
we're always hearing about the dying
wife i don't really i don't know this
this woman i haven't had i don't know
her at all and a lot of times for me to
be like emotionally moved by something i
feel like i gotta know who the person is
like i understand that anything with an
affliction of tumor or cancer can be a
very relatable thing because most of us
either know someone who has dealt with
that or has had someone personally deal
with that so i understand the context of
that is a very
sensitive thing and a very serious and
real relatable thing but at the from a
movie standpoint from characters
i'm like i don't know this woman so i
don't really
like do will i really care about what's
going on
yet that whole scene i thought was so
powerful and so so touching it just
really got to my heart there and it's
because of i think this beautiful
direction by frank darabont like the way
he he managed to handle so many
different things because this whole
thing
like with
the the powers being revealed the
ability to heal that comes in so late
into this movie and there's really
nothing that's foreshadowing that he can
do that
like nothing
yet it didn't feel left field to me it
felt
like it fit it worked and to me that
speaks volumes on how strong of a
direction frank garrett was able to
strike with this film because
in a lot of movies
you would think that and maybe there's
more subtle ways it was foreshadowed
because you strike some type of whimsy
fantasy like elements with mr jingles
who was a standout and was amazing
and kind of this angelic
supplement in a lot of ways you know
like
for dell or even to carry on uh i'm
i would like to look up stuff about mr
jingles i feel like there'd be a lot of
good think pieces about mr jingles on
the internet uh so i feel like you know
like have there's the way they struck
that like funny little quirkiness but
something that felt a little bit hiding
about it but never went too heightened
to the point where it didn't feel like
unrealistic
but there was this sort of you know
fantasy tone i would say not so much
execution but tone and a whimsy to the
carrot to to mr jingles that breathe a
lot of life into it so that way when you
do have the fantasy side of it where
they go they go full supernatural with
the reveal of his powers
it's somehow worked and that's when i
knew this film
is doing something really special
because
in a lot of movies if you were to
introduce something that late it could
feel kind of jarring but because it does
come as a surprise it does come as a big
reveal it does come like whoa what the
hell
yet
blended well
and it never felt like the movie just
took a big turn into something
different you know granted there are
things about it that i i thought
could have been amped up with a little
bit more writing you know some of the
relationship with tom hanks and his wife
she really felt like you know just the
most generic
wife
character i wasn't really watching this
movie going i want more from the wife i
want to see more of her
however whenever we did check into her
i'm like yep just tom hanks
at home after working the green mile and
then she just shows up in the background
to talk to him that's usually how it
goes uh you know there's a couple of
scenes that don't go that way with her
but yeah i felt like that was
underwritten
and you see like the other prison guards
like barry pepper and the other guy
who's worked with frank darabon a bunch
he's on the walking dead i believe he's
also in the midst uh he he's another
performer that i'm like yeah not a not a
vastly richly written character yet the
actor really elevated that performance a
lot where i i really liked whenever he
was on screen
uh
i i did find it kind of odd that there
wasn't
like
i i want to like chalk it up to the time
period but
i don't know
to me
i think if you're witnessing some
miraculous [ __ ] going down
like a freaking mouse being crushed to
death
and then boom healed and it's fine you
probably want to you probably want to
like talk about it you probably want to
go what was that what was going on i
felt if there was one thing i felt was
missing from this movie was was that
scene they tried acknowledging it at
when they are having
when tom hanks does have them over for
lunch and and being like i just thought
we could go the rest of the year without
talking about this i didn't i was hoping
he wouldn't bring it up i'm like come on
you want to talk about it you got to
tell you
i just can't imagine a scenario where
you just want to be loud i'm just going
to act like that never happened
no no no there's god
one of them in the group had to have
been like we have to discuss this
because this is
this is crazy like that's some crazy
[ __ ] so that was one part of it that i
thought was missing to me
um but other than that you know uh
everything from a technical standpoint i
thought the music was excellent the
score was very touching
uh the the cinematography was great you
know i think the way how at times you
could weave in and out of something that
felt
very
angelic to something that could feel
almost borderline horror and haunting uh
with it i loved the you know as much as
you do do some flashbacks and and switch
locations it was primarily a very
contained movie that took place at the
green mile it was very contained in that
regard you know i i feel like shawshank
redemption which also very contained
movie takes place at a prison the prison
felt so vast
that
this actually weird this this actually
felt more contained to me
than shawshank and i i really loved
just like checking in with that one
little strip the corridor now let's just
checking it right there i thought was
awesome so
everything i thought they did here was
great i loved the writing i loved so
much about this movie and yeah out of
the three it's definitely my favorite
one
and this wasn't my smoothest talk i
usually try to like say something in
there in the early on
to clarify that it might not be the
smoothness but then i usually feel like
no no no i did an all right job in the
end this time around i don't feel like i
i did as good of a job as i normally do
it's definitely
a little bit clunky here in my
discussion but yeah if you want my just
bottom line opinion i thought everything
about it was great just a couple of
missing points and some
amazing performances and
uh i did like the the religious
undertones and something that
felt like it could have especially with
the the parallels or drawing here could
have felt obnoxiously on the nose and
yet it never
it never crossed that line to the point
of like oh god guys i get it stop you
know like sometimes movies do that where
you are you do get to the point where
you're like i get it you're [ __ ]
clever
that this movie never got to me that
point because at the end of the day it
seemed like what came first
was the emotion and was the characters
so due to that
i really i really respected this one a
lot i loved it i thought it was great
thank you guys for voting for this one
and yeah you can subscribe leave a like
that would be very much appreciated and
hey
talk to you all soon
[Music]